لمتابعه اخر الاحصائيات واخر المعلومات
بشان التداعيات وتبعات هذا الزلزال من
داخل اداره الكوارث وطوارئ التركيه افاد
في انقره مراسله الجزيره معنا فرح الزمان
شوقي فرح زمان
ما الجديد الذي تريده افاد هذا الصباح
حسن في الحقيقه الجديد كما كان متوقعا
ارتفاع في الارقام القتلى الان يتجاوز
عددهم السته الاف قتيل والجرحى يتجاوزون
الفا نحن نشهد الان ارتفاع الارقام
بالالاف على الاقل بالنسبه للجرحى منذ
مساء يوم امس حتى صباح هذا اليوم يصل عدد
الجرحى الى اكثر من 37 والقتله الى اكثر
من سته الاف وهو ما يعني
انتشال المزيد من المدنيين خلال الساعات
الماضيه افاد تؤكد وقوع هزات ارتداديه
عديده منها ما كان خفيفا ومنها ما كان
متوسطا وبعضها تجاوز اربع درجات على مقياس
ريختر خلال الليله الماضيه لذلك ما زالت
المخاوف من حصول انهيارات الجديده حاضره
في الحقيقه لذلك تستمر اداره الطوارئ في
انقره باصدار التحذيرات من ضروره
عدم دخول تلك المباني المتضرره والابتعاد
عن اي مكان فيه تصدعات خوفا من حصول
انهيارات جديده ووقوع اصابات جديده
كان من الواضح حسن من خلال تصريحات نائب
الرئيس التركي ليلى امس او حتى من الصور
التي نشاهدها على وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
التركيه بان فتح الطرق بات افضل في هذه
المرحله لنقل الدعم اللوجستي خلال اليومين
الماضيين كان هناك مشكله في تامين الطرق
لايصال المساعدات ولتحرك طواقم الانقاذ
الى المناطق المتضرره والتي اعلنت كمناطق
منكوبه الوضع من هذه الناحيه اليوم يعتبر
افضل نسبيا رغم سوء الاحوال الجويه ايضا
تم تجهيز اغطيه وعدد اكبر من الخيام نصب
اكثر من 100 الف خيمه بحسب التصريحات التي
تصدر من هنا من رئاسه او من اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ لكن هنالك مشكله تتعلق بتوفير او
بايصال الطعام والخبز تحديدا للمدنيين
المتواجدين في تلك المناطق هناك حاجه
لتامين عدد اكبر من الاغطيه من الملابس
الشتويه لا سيما ان هيئه الارصاد الجويه
تتحدث عن انخفاض اكبر في درجات الحراره
وسوء الاحوال الجويه لذلك فتح الطرق
يتزامن ايضا مع تحديات ثانيه ووجود
احتياجات ثانيه على الارض حسن مساله
الكهرباء بحسب نائب الرئيس التركي ايضا من
المفترض ان تحل اليوم ستحل العديد من
المشكلات بطبيعه الحال لاحظنا ايضا ان عدد
الجرحى والمصابين الذين تم نقلهم من تلك
المناطق الى مناطق ثانيه عبر طائرات
السلاح الجوي قد زاد ايضا هنا في العاصمه
انقر في طريق الى هذا المكان لاحظت
ازدحاما شديدا حول بعض المشافي هناك عدد
من الجرحى وتحديدا المصابين باصابات بالغه
وصلوا الى العاصمه التركيه انقره ولكن
هنالك صور تظهر وجود تجمعات للمدنيين
المتضررين في مطارات المدن المنكوبه
يحاولون المغادره لذلك من المتوقع ان يتم
تخصيص طائرات مدنيه اكثر لنقل هؤلاء لكن
الخطوط الجويه تتحدث عن نقل 4000 شخص حتى
الان من تلك المناطق جوا الى مناطق ثانيه
بعضهم افضل الذهاب الى منازل الاقارب
والعائله
لا سيما بعد تضرر منازلهم بشكل كبير
اشاره اخرى حسن تتعلق هنا بالمدن الصناعيه
وزير الصناعه
اكد بان المدن الصناعيه في تلك المناطق
المنكوبه لم تتضرر كثيرا لكن الاشكاليه
الان تكمن في وصول الغاز وصول الغاز الى
تلك المعامل او حتى
للمدنيين حسن وهو امر يشكل تحدي كبير لا
سيما مع وجود اضرار وقعت في خطوط ايصال
الغاز لتلك المناطق يعني على رغم فتح
الطرق لكن ما زالت هناك الكثير من
التحديات فضلا عن تحديات رفع الانقاض
وانقاذ من بقي حيا تحت هذه الانقاد شكرا
لك من مقر افاد في انقره مراسله الجزيره
فرح الزمان شوقي وطبعا سنعود اليك في كل
جديد
يعلن من مركز اداره الطوارئ والكوارث في
انقره